[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
the death of george floyd federal trial
ex-officer and defendant thomas lane
takes the stand and a surge of
counterfeit opioids we want to bring
awareness from our community on just the
seriousness of this
this crisis plus the so-called daytona
beach serial killer mr hayes
acknowledged in his interview i don't
have a twin
he's the only person on this planet with
that genetic fingerprint here are
closing arguments from both sides but
first it was a harsh reality as a child
to see your father not be able to do
that the defendant's family takes the
stand in the movie theater murder trial
long crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
welcome everyone to law on crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin the defense on a florida shooting
death trial calls its first witnesses
including family members of the
defendant both the son and daughter of
retired police captain curtis reeves
testified friday as their father faces
murder charges for shooting and killing
a man in a movie theater eight years ago
reeves is charged with second-degree
murder in the death of chad olson reeves
said he shot olson in self-defense after
getting frustrated when olson was on his
cell phone during movie previews defense
attorneys say olson threw his cell phone
at reeves and came toward him to attack
that's when they say reeves shot olsen
in self-defense separate witnesses have
testified they never saw a cell phone
being thrown but some have said olson
hit reeves with popcorn from the bag
sitting on his own lap on friday his son
matthew who is now a tampa police
officer told the jury about when he
arrived at the scene as he was running
late to meet his parents for the movie
reeves daughter also testified telling
jurors about her childhood and the
changes her parents have gone through as
they've aged
one of the things you talked about is is
kayaking that's something you did with
your father yes sir and your mother yes
was there
a time that you can tell us about where
it kind of hits you that your father
couldn't do the things he used to be
able to do when it came to
kayaking maybe
sometime before 2014. yes sir it was
actually i moved into their house
i left my husband in march of 2013
excuse me april of 2013 and moved into
their home we actually went kayaking
that very same month so we went on the
kayaking trip and the kayak paddles are
two-part paddles where you have to press
in a little button and pull them apart
and uh it was a harsh reality as a child
to see your father not be able to do
that
he asked me for help to pull him apart
before riva's wife took the stand monday
the defense called an aging and mental
health expert to testify about reactions
when aging and older people's being
vulnerable
older people
with who are at risk for more medical
and physical issues
become vulnerable meaning they're at
risk
to
not be able to do things and not be able
to protect themselves in fact the things
that the the older population are most
afraid of
are
frailty
losing their health
being hurt and having an untimely death
joining us today is la county pub
deputy public defender sorry philip dube
and terry austin philip how strong of a
witness was this aging specials for
their defense and also looking the other
side to the prosecution scoring points
on cross
well i'm not sure that i would call this
you know geriatrician if you will a
strong witness for mr reeves because she
is portraying him as a grandpa walton
and the truth be told she wasn't at the
scene at the time of this shooting he
was pretty limber buoyant and and spry
you know he was quicker on the draw than
the victim was got that gun out and
fired away you would never know that he
was suffering from any type of
immobility incapacity or infirmity so i
think her testimony might be undercut
really by mr reeve's own conduct
at the time
yeah it's gonna be interesting to see
how they kind of square that peg with
what you see in the videos you said
terry does the defense's witness seem to
be attacking the prosecution's argument
uh that this wasn't self-defense or is
it something else
well i think the defense is solely
claiming that it was self-defense i mean
that is their only claim and i
wonder whether or not the jury is going
to buy that they're saying that he
feared death or serious bodily injury i
mean we
heard from the wife that he leaned
because he was in fear we heard from his
daughter there that she said he was
frail and it really upset her and you
know dr cohen is basically saying that
once you get to a certain age you're
extremely vulnerable and so the defense
is basically trying to say this is why
he reacted this way this is why he shot
the gun but i agree with phil
all together you know he moved quickly
so he couldn't have been too vulnerable
because he was able to shoot him in the
chest point blank yeah i'm curious as to
whether or not this is setting the stage
for reeves to testify himself or if this
is a substitute for him to testify only
to find out is to continue to watch the
law and crime network for capital gavel
coverage still ahead on law and crime
daily the opioid epidemic sweeping the
nation what you need to know to stay
safe
but first hear closing arguments from
both sides as the accused daytona beach
serial killer stands trial for murder
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
today and then locate lawn crime in the
channel guide and for only 1.99 a month
you can add the network to your bundle
watch lawn crime every day with youtube
tv we put you in the jury box
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily an
accused serial killer's case is now in
the hands of a forward jury as they are
set to begin deliberations after closing
arguments were presented monday in the
murder trial of robert hayes hayes is
being tried for the murders of three
daytona beach women more than 15 years
ago authorities say laquita gunther
julie green and iwana payne were sex
workers who were found dead shot in the
head in late 2005 and early 2006. the
cases went cold after an investigation
led to no suspects then 10 years later
another woman was murdered in west palm
beach after that killing hayes was put
under surveillance officials say his dna
match what was collected at the crime
scenes prosecutors presented their
closing arguments monday focusing on the
evidence they say points directly to
hayes
the evidence in this case is
by science it's supported by fact
and the evidence shows beyond a
reasonable doubt
that in december of 2005 excuse me
december 2005
it was mr hayes standing in that
alleyway
behind the gunther
pulling the trigger of a smith and
wesson 40 caliber ve
moments after he ejaculated into her
mouth
it shows there was mr hayes
who pressed the muzzle
of the same 40 caliber smith and wesson
ve into the back of julie green's head
leaving a burn mark from the firearm
out in the middle of a field in a
construction zone in the dark and it
shows beyond a reasonable doubt that it
was mr hayes who finally
sent a bullet through the front
of miss patton's nasal cavity passing
through her head in a dark field
again in daytona beach
within four weeks
hayes defense team spoke to the jury one
last time making their case saying there
were holds in the prosecution's case and
didn't prove hayes was the one
responsible for the women's death
in fact on all three of these cases
you have to make some kind of an
assumption
and there is no fact to show
that mr hayes
had a handgun
in his hand
at the time of the shooting of miss
gunter or at the time of the shooting of
ms greene or the time of the shooting of
miss patton
in fact there's no evidence at all that
he was even in town
when these
incidents happen
going back to gunter it's a christmas
holiday
the state didn't establish that he was
even in the location
just that he lived
in daytona beach
back to break down the alleged daytona
serial killer trial is la county deputy
public defender phillip dube and terry
austin terry did the prosecution's
closing leave you with any questions and
how long do you think the jury will
deliberate
brian i have no questions and i have no
doubt and i don't think it's going to
take the jury long to deliberate at all
the prosecution was excellent he went
through the case he talked about the
elements of this particular crime one he
said the victim is dead all of them were
dead no question they were shot in the
head and that's uncontested he said
basically that the second element was
that it was caused by the defendant and
he laid out for that jury the similarity
in the bullets and they were all dumped
by his home and the dna and then the
third thing he said that you're going to
have to find once you get the jury
instructions is that it was premeditated
and i think he made a good case by
talking about how it was planned and so
the jury i believe should come back with
a conviction fairly quickly all right so
philip terry thing's pretty quick
conviction but the question for you is
did the defense's closing sound more
like mitigation for sentencing are they
really trying to win this case
no it's definitely more like mitigation
brian
essentially what he's arguing or
downplaying is the power of
circumstantial evidence you know so what
that someone didn't come into court and
say yeah i saw the gun in his hand you
know or you know uh that somebody
physically saw him and these victims
together the power of circumstantial
evidence is going to uh
nail him frankly i think
what this defense attorney is trying to
do is condition this jury
into uh sparing him of the death penalty
in light of his age you've got to
remember he was 20 or 21 at the time he
was a college kid
and many years have gone by and he may
have in that interim led an otherwise
blameless life so we'll see we'll see
how it plays out coming up on law and
crime daily we're entering week five in
federal court as 3x officers stand trial
for the death of george floyd plus one
pill can kill authorities now seeing an
uptick in counterfeit opioids what you
need to know still ahead
[Music]
welcome back counterfeit drugs have been
found
been around for years but federal
officials are seeing more fake pills
containing oil points that could kill
law and crimes angela levy spoke with a
dea agent about the concerning trend
brian the opioid epidemic knows no
boundaries communities across the united
states are dealing with overdose deaths
and the dea is working to stop those
drugs from hitting the street the agency
is also announcing a new campaign to
educate the public
[Music]
cleveland ohio dea agents break down the
door of an apartment during a raid
inside they find counterfeit pills
containing the often fatal opioid
fentanyl over the years we've seen a
significant rise but it's really in 2020
we just saw it explode and it's been
extremely concerning for the dea jason
schumacher is the assistant special
agent in charge of the cincinnati office
of the dea he says fentanyl has driven
drug overdose deaths in the u.s
last year we lost over a hundred
thousand americans due to drug overdose
these drug trafficking organizations
operated out of mexico
they mimic
an identical hydrocodone percocet uh
adderall these type of drugs that are
commonly seen on the street and what's
concerning for us is 42
of these pills contain a lethal dose of
fentanyl at first glance these pills
look real but some are marked with
emojis enticing teens schumacher says
they get into the u.s through commercial
trafficking in what looks like a
legitimate business operation
others can come through the mail just
last week a mother and son in wilmington
north carolina were charged with
trafficking more than 50 000 counterfeit
pills payton mitchell is being held on
an 11.6 million dollar bond counterfeit
prescription pills laced with fentanyl
are deadly to fight the rise of
counterfeit pills the dea has launched
the one pill can kill campaign aiming to
educate the public about the danger and
efforts to root out drug dealers and
their operations
first of all it's greed it's it's all
about making money it's a business it's
an organization that they're trying to
push the poison out to our communities
so they really don't care that a hundred
thousand people died last year
and agent schumacher told me that the
dea actually seized 10 million of those
counterfeit pills last year brian
thanks angeannette l.a county public
defender philip dube and co-host terry
austin are back as we discuss the case
of counterfeit opioids terry what do you
think police and even lawmakers can do
to fight the push uh these fake
prescription pills out of our
communities well look i think the fake
pills are a problem i mean
seriously if it's killing people but i
think the real problem is even deeper
than that it is the opioid addiction
that is the real problem here and i do
know that the health and human services
has prioritized this i mean it's an it's
an epidemic the fact that a hundred
thousand deaths occurred last year
they're trying to get five different
things started they want better research
better data better pain medication
better treatment and better prevention
and if they do all of that hopefully
they can address the opioid addiction
and that will help as far as the fake
pills are concerned as well yeah philip
one of those uh plans of attacks are
education and the ability to identify
the fakes from the real pills that seems
to be like a smart plan but is there
more we can we can do or law enforcement
can do to protect ourselves and our
nation
oh yes but you know short of a ban or an
embargo on the active ingredients
and you know
detox and rehab and you know all of that
kind of stuff and dealing with um
the effects and the uh
uh the permanent mind altering effects
not to mention all the health uh
problems that arise out of the drug what
pharmaceutical companies and the medical
communities should be working on
is an antidote to counteract these toxic
effects of the drugs because right now
it doesn't seem like they can give the
patients anything when they are
overdosing on the fentanyl so perhaps if
they come out with something to
counteract that at a minimum and in the
short term they can save lives
absolutely no anger is the dea finding
fentanyl in other drugs
yeah they sure are brian and it's being
found in things like cocaine that that's
a stimulant right but fentanyl is being
laced on that cocaine or put into that
cocaine and a lot of these
agents think that that's so the drug
dealers can make their product more
addictive it's also been found in
marijuana as well so a number of drugs
are being laced with this street
fentanyl all right again check out the
dea's website learn get educated and
take care of yourselves and your loved
ones thank you everyone for your update
on this story when we come back a third
ex-officer stands trial and takes the
stand in the death of george floyd our
legal analysts break down the charges
and testimony of ex-officer thomas lane
still ahead on law and crime daily
[Music]
welcome back to long crime daily closing
arguments are presented as the three men
convicted in the death of the mod arbory
stand trial for charges of federal hate
crimes father and son gregory and
trouser michael along with neighbor
william roddy bryan all face federal
hate crime charges in aubry's death on
monday prosecutors told jurors that the
defendants targeted aubry because of his
race saying they refused to help him as
he was dying because they considered
aubry to be quote subhuman defense
attorneys argued that mcmichaels acted
in self-defense and were attempting to
perform a since repealed and replaced
citizen's arrest last year all three men
were convicted in aubry's murder in a
georgia state trial all three were
sentenced to life in prison brian is
eligible for parole after 30 years
served the mcmichaels will serve 20
years on top of their life sentence
prosecutors say aubrey a 25 year old
black man was jogging near his brunswick
georgia home when the mcmichaels began
tailing him in their pickup truck
traffic michael eventually shot and
killed aubry brian captured the incident
on his cell phone
also in federal court the third and
final ex-officer charge in the death of
george floyd takes a stand in his own
defense two tao thomas lane and jay
alexander king all face charges for
depriving floyd of his rights in may
2020. last week tao and king testified
on monday court resumed with the
testimony from thomas lane a rookie
officer called to the scene lane is the
only defendant who is not charged with
failure to intervene presumably because
he asked derek shovin multiple times to
change floyd's position last year
shoving was convicted in floyd's murder
in state court and has pled guilty to
violating floyd's civil rights in
federal court on monday lane told jurors
he was a rookie officer who deferred to
chauvin's veteran experience lane
testified he also asked chauvin to move
floyd onto his side expressing concern
for excited delirium body camera footage
shows how that moment played out
on the side
okay
[Music]
lane's charges are different than the
other defendants so how does his
testimony need to be to differ sorry and
was it enough for not guilty
oh that's a good question brian let me
just tell you as long as he can point to
the fact that that police department did
not have a firmly established
intervention protocol with actual
measures that a fellow officer has to
take when they see another colleague or
officer using illegal unwise or
excessive tactics if they don't have
that in place at least he asked
questions of the other officer even a
superior one as to whether or not they
should ease up or do something different
he wasn't completely passive in the
process
now on the other hand he could have
maybe done a little bit more other than
just passively asked they should have an
established code word that lets fellow
officers at the scene know for example
that bad tactics are being used if that
doesn't work then i guess the question
is are they trying to just step up and
just push that officer off their their
victim we'll see yeah if it's not in the
books now i'm sure it's going to be in
the books for the police department
going forward terry do you think any of
the officers would have been better off
pointing the finger at each other and
why do you think they didn't
i think it makes far more sense for them
not to point their finger at each other
because that could really backfire if
you think about it i think the tactic
that they took is the better tactic they
basically said look we did what we were
trained to do as philip was mentioning
and if anything they didn't train us
well enough because we did everything we
were told
and basically i think each of them also
has their own independent argument of
course tao basically said that wasn't
his job he was watching the crowd and
lane is arguing that he did try to
intervene he did try to say roll over
and i think king probably has the more
difficult argument but he too was in a
position where he was following order so
i think it's better for all of them to
have the same story stick to the story
assert their individual defenses and
then basically try to win that way all
right we'll see how it goes as this is
kind of wrapping up in this case thank
you both and thank you for joining us
here on long crime daily we'll see you
next time as we discuss justice in
america
[Music]
you